Transcriber: Habip Bahçecioğlu
Gözden geçirme: Rana Karjy
Çıkaracağım.
Çünkü gerçekten yazacağını söylediği
gibi gözlükle görülmüyor.
Karşı taraf çok fena durumda.
Herkese merhaba, Öncelikle beklediğiniz
için hayranım.
Sonuna kadar burada olduğunuz
için teşekkür ediyorum.
Bazen sona.
Sona kalmak biraz az solistlik gibi
görünür ama aslında en kötüsüdür.
Çünkü insanlar yorulur, sıkılır, başka
işleri vardır, o işlere koşturmak
isterler, gitmek isterler,
hava almak isterler.
Ona rağmen burada olmanız
benim için çok kıymetli.
Çok teşekkür ederim.
Şunu söyleyeyim haftanın beş günü aşağı
yukarı televizyonlarda konuşan kafa gibi
çıkar konuşurum.
Ama karşınızda aslında kalabalık
karşısında konuşma sorunu olan, travması
olan bir insan var.
İlkokulda üçüncü sınıfta 3 Kasım.
Bizim, benim büyüdüğüm ilçenin, Kars'ın
Susuz ilçesinin Kurtuluş günüydü ve orada
şiiri benim okumamı istemişlerdi.
Bir tek ben ezberlemiştim.
Daha doğrusu hiç kalabalık önünde
konuşamaz gibi bir endişeye kapılmadım.
Nasıl olsa ezberlemiş , şiiri nasıl
olsa okuyacaktır diye beni
kürsünün önüne attılar.
Şiiri ezbere biliyordum ama
birilerinin karşısında
bunu yapamazdım.
Yapamadım.
Kürsüden ağlayarak koştum ve indim.
Onun için bu tedris konuşmacısı olur
musunuz diye sorduklarında biraz
tedirgin oldum.
Çünkü bu kameranın karşısında
konuşmaya benzemiyor.
Burada insanlar insanlarla birebir
karşı karşıyasınız ve bizim
konferanslara da benzemiyor.
Konferanslara gidiyoruz işte.
Hükümeti eleştiriyoruz, alkış alıyoruz,
muhalefeti eleştiriyoruz.
Bu sefer hükümet yanlıları alkışlıyor,
alkışların alıyoruz vesaire.
Bu böyle bir şey de değil.
Burada karşıt karşınızdaki insanlar
sizden bir ilham veren
bir hikaye bekliyorlar.
O nedenle de bunu verebilme ihtiyacıyla,
arzusuyla bu sahneye çıkıyorsunuz.
Ben de bunu yapmak niyetindeyim.
Hazırlandım, kopya çekeyim istedim.
Meslektaşlarımın konuşmalarını dinledim.
3 4 gündür sürekli bizim meslektaşların
tedx konuşmalarını dinliyorum ama
dinledikçe de moralim bozuldu.
Şimdi Nevşin Mengü çıkmış mesela,
tedx konuşması yapmış .
Kadın hem triatlon yapmış , hem Ironman
yarışına katılmış , hem vegan.
Ben gördüğünüz gibi gayet etçil işte
spor geçmişi de yapmışlığım var.
Kürek takımında çalışmıştım var ama bu
aralar maalesef sporla falan çok şey.
Bir iyi geçinen bir insan değilim.
Ne anlatacağım sonra açtım Emin
Çapa'nın ki ne dinledim ya.
Emin Çapa da Newtondan bahsetmiş ,
Arşimet, Arşimet den bahsetmiş vesaire.
Ya ben mühendislik okudum bana hiç ilginç
gelmiyor Yani Newton'un kurallarını ,
işte modern fiziğin temellerini
atmasını vesaire anlatmış .
Oradan Türkiye'ye bağlamış ,
ilginç şeyler yapmış .
Ama bana ilginç gelmiyor.
Çünkü ben angarya olarak gördüğüm bütün
eğitim hayatım boyunca fizik dersinde
suyun kaldırma kuvveti de, yerçekimi
kuvveti de vesaire bunlar
benim için hep angarya.
Böyle bir şey de olamaz.
O zaman bir gazeteci olarak ne
anlatabilirim, ne ne verebilirim
insanların en azından bir kişinin dahi
olsa umutlarına hangi umudu katarım diye
düşündüm, taşındım ve herkesin bana çok
sıkça sorduğu sorunun yanıtını anlatmaya
karar verdim.
O da şu.
Ben.
Böyle burnunun dikine giden biriyim.
İlkokul beşinci sınıfta kompozisyon
yarışmasına sokmak istediler beni.
Gittim.
Ne mutlu Türküm Diyene!
İle ilgili bir kompozisyon.
Yaz diye bir şey.
Bir cümle yazdım devamını getiremedim
kağıdı bıraktım koşarak.
Yan sınıfta resim yarışması vardı.
Kuduz ile ilgili bir yarışma idi.
Kuduz ile ilgili bir afiş
yapın diye vermişlerdi.
O yarışmada birinci oldu.
Yani kompozisyon yarışmasından sıkılıp
kaçıp resim yarışmasına katılan ve orada
birinci olan bir insanın böyle bir.
Değişik bir asi tarafım var ve
hayatım hep bunlarla geçti.
Devlet Parasız Yatılı Okulu
sınavını kazandım.
Aslında Kabataş Erkek Lisesine
gidebilecek durumdaydım.
Fakat Kars nere, İstanbul nere?
Yani 9 buçuk yaşında bir çocuğu herhalde
hiçbir anne baba taaaa İstanbul'a götürüp
yatılı okul okuma sını göze almazdı.
Yani böyle bir gerçek varken Kars'taki
yatılı okulda okudum ve çok değişik ilgi
alanlarım vardı.
Resim yapardım ama acayip kimya bilirdim.
Acayip fizik bilirdim.
Böyle öğretmenler bana işte dersi
anlatmadan anlat, vardıkları dersle
ilgili sorular sorar, yapmamı
isterlerdi vesaire.
Sonra üniversite sınavını
aşamasına geldik.
Resim yapmak istiyordum.
Ben güzel sanatlar okumak istiyordum.
Hatta geçen gün 19 Mayıs'la ilgili
bir paylaşımda gördüm.
Biz lise son sınıftayken yapılan bir 19
Mayıs töreninde açılmış devasa bir
Atatürk posteri vardı .
Yani şöyle söyleyeyim.
Üç metre yüksekliğinde, iki küsür metre
genişliğinde devasa bir poster.
O posteri iki arkadaşımla
birlikte ben yapmıştım.
Yani onu görünce o kadar gururlandım ki,
o kadar kendimi iyi hissettim ki.
O posterleri yaptığım dönemde resim okumak
istemiştim ama kimya öğretmenim
şöyle bir şey dedi.
Ya Deniz dedi sen ne yapacaksın dedi.
Bak resim yaparken kimya öğrenemez.
Ama kimya okursan resim yapmaya
devam edebilirsin.
Bana mantıklı geldi yani.
Evet mantıklı ben kimya okurum hem
boyaları falan da öğrenirim, kimyasalları
da öğrenirim, resim de yaparım ama kimya
da mühendis olurum, üstüne akademisyen
olurum, profesör olurum
vesaire gibi bir şey.
Üniversiteye geldim.
Atatürk Öğrenci Yurdu var, Cebeci de.
Eskiden adı Steyr duymuş ve bu sağ sol
çatışmalarında ülkücülerin en yoğun
olduğu yermiş .
Yurttan içeri girdim.
6 kişilik bir oda.
Bir yatağın üstünde biri
oturmuş ama yaşlı .
Yani ben daha 16 yaşındayım.
O 30 yaşında.
Merhaba dedi.
Adın ne?
Korktun mu?
Üniversite yurduna gelmişsiniz.
Böyle bıyıklı falan.
30 yaşında bir adam.
Yani bizimle aynı odada kalacak.
Deniz dedim.
Kaç yaşındasın Deniz dedi.
Ben de yetmiş iki doğumluyum dedim.
Aaaaa dedi.
Sen dedi Deniz Gezmiş.
Haksızlıktan sonra doğan tayfadansın.
Evet dedim.
Adımı da galiba oradan aldım dedim.
Böyle bir soğuk rüzgar esti.
Şimdi ülkücülerin çok güçlü
olduğu bir yer.
Siz dedim ben Ahmet dedi.
Ziraat Fakültesinde okuyorum dedi ve.
Cezaevinden yeni çıkmıştı .
Yanlış hatırlamıyorsam 12
Eylül'de tutuklanmış .
88 de işte o arada herhalde
cezaevinde geçirmiş .
Sonra biz çok iyi arkadaş olduk.
Ben ona derslerinde yardımcı oldum.
O bana destek oldu.
Dayak o yurtta dayak yemeden çıktıysa
tek şeyi Ahmet olmuştu.
Beni korudu, kolladı.
Yani sırf adından dolayı dayak
yiyebileceğim bir ortamdı bu.
Bu psikoloji insanı ister istemez politik
eleştiriyor ve ben de
Orta Doğu Teknik Üniversitesi
gibi bir ortam düşünün.
Sürekli eylem, sürekli böyle protesto,
sürekli şey.
Kendimi Deniz ismiyle birlikte
orada buldum.
Evet, kimya okuyordum.
Acayip zor derslerimiz vardı .
Mesela kütle transferi diye bir ders vardı
ısı transferi diye bir ders vardı .
Acayip zor konulardı.
Biz lisede görmüştük fizik, kimya,
biyoloji ama bu bambaşka bir şeydi.
Ben onların arasına böyle siyaset
sıkıştırmaya başlamıştım.
Sonra?
Birden kendimi öğrenci derneğinin
çıkardığı .
Yayın organının editörü olarak buldum
ve kapaklarını yapmaya başladım.
Kapak karikatürlerini çizmeye başladım.
Sonra müstehar isimle bir
köşe yazmaya başladım.
Başka bir isimle o köşede.
İşte üniversite yönetiminin Şimdi
rektörler öğrencilere bu kadar yakın.
İşte ulaşıyorsunuz, fotoğraf
çektiriyorsunuz falan.
Bizim okuduğumuz yıllarda rektörler
böyle imparator gibiydi.
Bırakın muhatap olmayı , yüzünüze
bile bakmazlar.
Yani öyle öyle bir ortam vardı .
12 Eylül askeri darbesi olmuş ,
üniversiteler tarumar olmuş , rektörler
direk YÖK kurulmuş , YÖK
tarafından atanmış .
Hepsi böyle kendini çok
güçlü görüyor falan.
Öyle bir üniversite ortamı ve Orta Doğu
Teknik Üniversitesi 1980'den sonra bir
daha patlamasını , bir daha hareketlenmesi
falan diye böyle acayip
baskı altında bir yer.
Ve ben orada asistan olmak istedim.
Mastır yapayım dedim vesaire.
Biyoloji bölümüne de kapak attım.
Amacım bir biyoloji profesörü olmaktı .
Bu virüs programı virüslerin, corona
virüsün tartışıldığı programlarda
Twitter'dan bize en çok şey
ile saldırıyorlardı .
Ya adam gazeteci.
Virüs konusuyor iste.
MRNA nedir bilir misin?
Ne ne konuşuyorsun falan gibi.
Twitter'dan böyle şeyler geliyor,
eleştiriler geliyor.
Evet biliyordum.
Yani MRNA yı de biliyordum,
DNA’yı da biliyordum.
Moleküler biyoloji de biliyordum
bütün bunları tartışırken.
Çünkü bunların eğitimini almıştım.
4 sene kimya nın üzerine yaklaşık
5 sene de biyoloji okumuştum.
Ve.
Bu benim için acayip bir şeydi.
Rüyaydı yani.
Şimdi çerçevesi tedx in düş peşine
diyoruz ve bu benim için bir çeşit düştü .
Yani resim gibi bir sevdadan.
Bunun uğruna vazgeçmiştim.
Ama bir gün.
Bunu anlatamıyorum.
Başıma kötü şey geldi.
Kendimi bir hücrede buldum.
İki hafta çok ağır işkence gördüm.
Yapmadığım bir şeyi yapmamı,
kabul etmemi istediler.
Ve kabul etmedim.
Gözümü hastanede açtım.
Yine kabul etmedim çünkü böyle
bir şey yapmamıştım.
Gerçek benim için bir taneydi.
O gördüğü gerçeği orda ölümüne savundum.
Ve.
Gerçekle, gerçekle aramdaki nikah orda
kıyıldı.
Gazetecilik mesleği Biliyorsunuz.
Biraz önce hep düş dedik.
Gazi hocam metavers evreninden bahsetti,
sanaldan bahsetti, gölgelerden bahsetti
bizim mesleğimizde.
Her şeyini o gerçeğe borçlu.
Temel görevimiz o gerçeği
bulup ortaya çıkarmak.
Halkın duymasını sağlamak, halkın
haber alma hakkına hizmet etmek.
İşte ben orada gerçeğin ne kadar
önemli olduğunu gördüm.
Hayatım pahasına gördüm.
Ölmeyi göze alarak gördüm.
Çıktığımda oradan özgürlüğüme kavuştum da.
Tam dibe vurmuştu.
İşimi kaybetmiştim.
Dedemi kaybetmiştim.
Üç gün adımı sayıklamıştı .
Ama nerede olduğumu ailem bile bilmiyordu.
Sevgilim beni terk etmişti.
O da o kadar süre arayıp sormadığı için
artık benimle yapamayacağını şey yapmış ,
karar vermiş .
Sonra ODTÜ'ye gittim.
Bölüme işte şey yapacağım, artık yeniden
işe başlamak istiyorum vesaire.
Elime bir kağıt tutuşturdular.
Dediler ki İfade vermen gerekiyor.
Bir adli soruşturma bitti.
Beraat ettin anladık.
Ama bir de idari soruşturma var, idari
soruşturmada da ifade vermen lazım.
Bizim bölümün hocaları herhalde biz
savcı değiliz falan diye ifade
almayı kabul etmemişler.
Psikoloji bölümünden bir hocaya gittim.
Oturdum karşısına ama o kadar kötüyüm
ki tam dibe vurmuş, tam bitmişim .
Yani benim için her şeyin sonuna gelmiş .
İşimi kaybetmiş , her şeyimi kaybetmişim.
Hanımefendi dedi ki Psikolog, psikolog,
psikoloji bölümünde hoca.
Ya dedi
Rahat ol dedi.
Bak 1978'de dedi, orada ben oturmuştum.
Burada da başka bir hoca oturmuştu.
Seninle aynı durumdaydım.
Beni dağıtmak istiyorlardı .
Benim de ifademi almak istiyorlardı .
Ama geçti gitti.
Bak bugün burada hocayım dedi.
Takma kafana, rahat ol falan.
Ben ağlamaya başladım.
Bu.
Gerçekten.
İnsanın karakterine, onuruna, sahip
olduğu bütün değerlere yönelik
bir saldırıdır.
Bu işkence meselesi.
Ben ağlamaya başlayınca hanımefendi
durumu anladı, vaziyeti anladı ve
ilgilenmeye başladı.
Sen boş ver dedi soruşturmayı.
Sen düzenli olarak gel,
haftada bir görüşelim.
Bedava psikolog buldum.
Ve
Düzenli olarak gittim.
Çok hoşuma gitmeye başladı böyle artık.
Bu arada sürem bitiyor hemen toparlayayım.
Dedi ki Telafi edebilirsin kardeşim dedi.
Her şeyi telafi edebilirsin.
Yeter ki hayatta ol.
Bunu hepinize söylüyorum.
En sıkıştığını zamanda bile
her şeyi telafi etme şansınız var.
Sonra yaparım dedim.
Bir arkadaşımın annesi beni güya
ters motivasyon yapacak.
Demişti ki Ya senden bir şey olmaz, ya
dört duvar içinde geçer hayatın ya da bir
duvarın dibinde cesedini bulurlar.
Öyle değil dedim kendi kendime.
Ben Kars'ın Susuz ilçesinde küçük
bir köy okulunda okumuşum.
Devlet parasız yatılı okulunda devletin
yarattığı fırsat eşitliği ile gelmişim.
Ankara'da, ODTÜ'de okumuşum.
Profesör olacağım vesaire.
Bunları başarmıştım.
Bırakır mıyım hiç ?
Her şeyi telafi edeceğim ve sıfırdan
başlayacağım dedim ve gazeteciliğe
öyle başladım.
O dergide çalışmıştım, kapak çizmiştim,
köşe yazmıştım vesaire.
Onun yardımıyla.
Gazeteciliğe başladım.
Sonra Bosna'ya gittim, Bosna'da çalıştım,
Afganistan'a gittim, Afganistan'da
çalıştım, Irak'ta çalıştım,
Filistin'de çalıştım.
Birdenbire bir savaş muhabirine dönüştüm
ama bir taraftan da üniversitede
işi kaybettim.
Ama eğitim devam ediyordu.
97 yılında işte artık tez aşamasına
gelmişim, sunum yapmam lazım vesaire.
İsmet Berkan bizim Ankara temsilcisiydi.
Dedi ki Gidip Netanyahu'ya İsrail
Başbakanı röportaj yapacaksın şu tarihte.
Ben de dedim ki Benim dedim
o tarihte sınavım var.
Bir karar ver kardeşim dedi.
Ya gazeteci olacaksın.
Ya profesör olacaksın.
O gün gazeteci olmaya karar
verdim ve gittim.
Netanyahu ile röportaj yaptım.
Ve o gün bugündür gazetecilik yapıyorum.
Bütün bunları niye anlattım?
Şunun için anlattım.
Hayat.
Iyi karşılaşmaların ve doğru kararların.
Sonuçlarından ibarettir.
Bugün burada bir gazeteci olarak
karşınızda duruyorsam bunu biraz önce
saydıklarımı düşünün, işte kimya
öğretmenime borçluyum, ODTÜ'deki
psikologa borçluyum.
İsmet Berkana borçluyum.
Yani beni seçime zorlayan insanlara
borçluyum ve verdiğim
doğru kararlara borçluyum.
O insanlarla, o iyi insanlarla
karşılaşma saydım.
O iyi karşılaşmalar hayatımda olmasaydı
bugün belki başka bir serüvenin
içinde olacaktım.
Ama benim hayatım o iyi karşılaşmaların,
doğru kararlarının ve çalışma hırsının,
azmin, her şeyi telafi edebileceğimi
olan inancımın bir ürünüdür.
Onun ürünü olarak karşınızdayım.
Beni dinlediğiniz için teşekkür ederim.